[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm coming from a family seven children
three sisters four brothers and my
parents we live an average life very
religious life my father it was an
Orthodox Jew and I went oh hey des
I want polish school and I never met
trade what I remember from my childhood
was a small family not very wealthy we
all lived in in a neighborhood which
later was the ghetto my father was a
printer had a printer shop and worked
there with a helper my mother was a
housewife we were two children we used
to walk to school quite a long time and
took an hour perhaps and on foot we met
children together so we did not walk
along and talked and we saw I didn't
study poetry on the way so it was sort
of nice we had nine children we had you
know five brothers and four sisters we
are right now over here three two
brothers and one sister
we had also two nephews in a grandfather
in our house and we remain only three of
us from all of them all of them when
living in Chester how we had a shop from
Taylor in my father was a tailor we all
children worked in the shop in the
tailoring we had a wonderful time
as kids we are there we played we belong
to Zion this organization we play
ping-pong football anything what we had
was a wonderful time I personally live
a social good life I would say the
average life because in my time that
time I had a good trade
and I was mating making family so that
time if you had enough to feed yourself
and to buy for yourself nice clothes and
once a week if you was able to go to a
movie with your girlfriend
that was a lush I person who asked you
know a kid over there something like
that how come you know you don't play it
isn't that where he said you were Jewish
I said what's it different so he said
you killed Christ I said what I didn't
understand you know but you know he said
you killed Christ I said I didn't kill
him
what do you want for me he said you
killed him so that was very the religion
and I was got another thing to do in in
the school in this city we had three
miles away from from we lived whenever
we had the holy shrine over there and
chance to have the Polish she said
chance knock over that was the biggest
Church whether you talked to and if then
he gonna tell you the same thing then
chance the hope was the biggest
anti-semitic city I make so much morning
and I was working two shifts and I was
vote used and then the factory nervous
working and I had two children really I
had a better life this is beside money I
mean money was no question it's like so
at the split the life was this was one
child was [ __ ] 1933
have been married we had a child I was a
very successful businessman my father
knew it politics he was all his life in
this so I heard them when I was a child
for 19 I was born in 1924 of it 1928
that was a little high five years six
years I always hear whole nights used to
stay at the radio and hear all his
speeches at that time I didn't
understood who's who was speaking you
know but later I found out he knew it is
going to be something oh we didn't know
we didn't understand too much you know
what's going on I see we didn't know and
even they said you know Hitler and
Palestine you're gonna go to Palestine
you're gonna get it let's come across
something like that you killed Christ we
didn't you know we didn't know nothing
as you know I I didn't know it was you
know it's gonna be so bad see we wasn't
organized see nobody told nothing I
don't even really want to go away the
father than the one that s you didn't
want to leave your father water you
stood with the family all together no we
wasn't trained to have a gun we wasn't
trained to have a knife we wasn't trying
to know for this kind of business of it
you know stay away from me stay away
stay away stay away we did we was
nothing you know we just worked it all
went to school and went to the
Paulie Scoob we went to Hebrew school in
there and they go home in their workers
in the house well I wasn't the street in
one day bumps coming down so ever better
stuff to go back to the houses in Iran
it was a read at that time a lot of
people killed and we hide it so it took
too long in 39 when Germans took over
Czestochowa after very very short fight
during that time we ran my family and oh
I I remember hiding in a cellar probably
when they bombarded the city and hiding
from the Germans from chase how today I
thought about their from from chairman
board there was only 25 miles you know
we were sunny if not too far away from
from them over there that's why they was
in 1939 they started Friday in Sunday
ten o'clock they was already in the city
it could be there was they at night I
didn't see it because an idea was
slipping oh but that day Saturday I
walked out and I I see them fighting in
Sunday morning when I walked out over
there was ten o'clock I took a walk
three miles up to the city hall over
there was three miles from my house to
the city of Oliver they took a walk over
there we see the gentleman's was another
one over a cop ID city it was a friend
of my father and I walked out of it I
went in over there his son was a friend
of mine and you know we I know that also
Taylor and his name was mr. blitz and he
said to me is now was time to kill
herself at men and I looked at him I
didn't know what he was talking about
and and I went up to the city hall and I
when a wave I asked the son if he wants
to go for the walk he said no as I went
myself I went up three miles over there
and so the Germans and all the city all
I wanted to see they put their German
flag up and everything like that I see
the wall sir
after when I walked back I walked back
in the in the evening I went again over
there and he was killed or rather he
throwed him step mister blitz so he went
up on the third floor and he threw
himself down and he killed himself
the next morning all the people they
tell us me to buy nets over there and
everything we lost the bloody Monday
they call it bloody Monday we lost at
the bloody Monday 300 to 400 people they
just
raus raus out out out out out out a
metre by net and everything out out and
out and then they had that they they
they show you the way to go today to the
green of it all the bayonet was opened
with the guns and everything like that
just like that meter by narrative was
golden order at any money this was the
blood money they started right in the
morning and this was our first a the
first I mean the first day they bloody
Monday over there
they ordered all Jewish population of
that city to get to certain points
gather and then that happened they
picked at random just every so on and
just shuttin people there and I was in
the ballots there were quite a few
thousand people and then we just had
been released to go home and since then
we know what to expect
every day another branch of the German
troops of the young guns of this topo
for the city hall have been picking up
people in the street at random whatever
they could to do their work at the first
of all they tore out the you still
issues from the houses they took away
everything they put us between three
five family in a tomb in a two-bedroom
apartment so I chose well Abed my
father's printers shop was closed the
Germans took over the machinery my
school was closed so our teachers
decided to continue education in their
home so I remember we walked in
all groups to their homes for further
instructions
then slowly one teacher disappeared with
the know where doctors disappeared we
didn't know where it was all hushed
maybe because I was a child then but
maybe also people really didn't know it
was very gradually done there were
rumors that they were taken to another
city to work or they were needed because
in telling intelligentsia as we call it
millions we're slowly disappearing from
the city doctors professors teachers
directors slowly disappeared so they
were the first to go after why we did
not study at all but they ought to want
people to work any kind of work not to
work what is productive productive only
you know to keep Jews hard-working so I
said I'm a mechanic and I want to do I
can do any kind of work so that took me
to work what I gave me idea diced I try
to do the best I mean the best as a
mechanic not the best for them as a
mechanic to show to be needed to can
keep there for the children for the
house
Sunday Claude they create together six
or seven months later and they came into
Chester because this was only thirty or
forty mines from the German border then
[Music]
we start to feel how difficult it is to
get food to get the first aid and I drew
was not allowed to leave together
we had some reaction from the Jewish day
they create a Jewish administration and
I would say used to get 900 or 1000
calories for each head that wasn't the
beginning later was even not less than
that and
[Music]
between young people had to go and to
work for the Germans the Jewish
administration used to point out who has
to go to work we had no money to leave
for this jobs were not available so we
struggle I used to go out with my I mean
out of the Ethel I took of my Arvin and
asking money my father's friend for help
understand we survived just you know
just whatever we could was very hard
begging people please help me we did
have some nice people who my father
recipes used to help them to and they
gave me I was caring on my shoulder call
it the book suck it's not it's a what he
called it in the back you carry stuff
back back pain and I was had potatoes
following day after young people they
surrounded us and put us on a big market
left and right the young ones even - we
just plain lucky that we got them on
this side my sister and my mother were
separated the Golan's and I was
screaming I said mama I was crying and
one of the who surrounded us was a
Jewish guy who health we had to help and
he said you'd be happy because you going
to water and he shot me up yeah I said
like somebody says your life is gonna be
safe and I said no my life's green
so he shot me up don't scream so I was
separated - sisters - sisters and this
was then before we knew it there was a
very harsh knock on the door the door
burst open assessment came in with
rifles out out out out in German and we
were forced out when I never saw my home
anymore after that
we were taken out into the street very
fast very loud I probably was shocked
and know what's happening but still I
had my mother my father another girl
young girl who lived with us who helped
my mother also was taken and they
arranged this quickly with rifles in
fives and five and five and five and all
my neighbors were coming out of their
houses and apartments and five-cent
fives and fives were arranged that way
and marched forward and we came to a
certain spot where the Germans separated
people and because the five people were
always members of the family they knew
exactly what they were doing they
separated the families so first my
mother was separated of course with the
with a gun pointing to left-right
left-right my mother and the girl
worked with her worth one side my father
and my brother and I to the other side
at that point my father wanted to run to
my mother to go with her well they hit
him with a gun and not killed him just
sitting pushing away and he would went
back to us mother disappeared I didn't
know then where she went left later I
found out that it was the first
transport to Treblinka
so she was lost to us we did not know
where she went
my father and I my brothers remained
together for a why the German assented
my brother and my father to work on a
railroad track they sent us to work
somewhere else every day we returned to
the same place were they stationed us
and one day my father and brother did
not return again I didn't know at that
time what happened to them later I found
out from witnesses that they were both
shut on the railroad in the back at that
time I didn't know but from that moment
when I was left alone
what other Jews who were left alone
without any links to the family and I
was barely 15 them every day a certain
part of the city has to be gathered in a
certain place where they have the tide
it which one has to go right and left
this mean dead
or to be alive
it was Hasek hogwash schneider oxen
gesellschaft that was called it was the
labor camp in Czestochowa somewhere on
the outskirts of the city and what we
did was we they were bringing shells
from anti-aircraft guns or ammunition
and the shells that were destroyed or
partially destroyed or bend were
restored and that factory now I had a
wife and a kid stealing together which
hasn't been touched yet he knew I have a
sick child he said by us in Germany we
are not keeping people like this we are
given to the site of the injection
because the cut they did their country
has nothing goes from such a people if
would mean my son I would do the same he
advised me we went with Chairman's of an
inside that Hasegawa and we come in
every the first thing they lined us up
all 300 people and we went up one slide
there was one huge room for the 300
people was 300 people 150 day and on one
sided here and one 150 the other side
was only one bathroom there and that's
the way we was inside and this was the
voice they would other parents the first
cry out that night we was choking and
crying I was 15 and I was one of the
youngest and camp all the younger
children were killed and murdered - yes
I understand one thing the children 2
years old and the night became thousand
year old they knew like Russ that they
will be killed I told you the first side
was I have the sick child when their
liquidate the ghetto that took a talk
the way they talked they took people to
show them before I came into the my
apartment the policeman told miss was
talk in there took a man went up I mean
from the civil Jews they went up
reported a sleeping child down and this
was the end from this child they start
to build a small ghetto from all these
people who were left in that factory not
little do that they have picked women
and they must with them to that small
place where Jewish people used to live
and to clean up and they were going
about 10 12 enroll the women is tales
and everything which is needed to clean
up brushes my wife took the child in put
in one of these pails and go in vision
10 or 12 in a row they went into that
little place ready ghetto will be now
going back she hit the kids under the
bed in that little yellow overnight the
kid was by herself until the next day
she came back again and gave her some
faith this was for a few days and at the
end they took all of the rest and put in
that ghetto and all these people who
were sent to factories to work had to go
back every day into that new ghetto now
here again we had a whole family
together we had one night we went home
was to two guys to fall asleep in the
place and we was counted to 200 in
in 1998 we took one guy out because
every 50 they had responsible one guy
they took out the guy you know in the
Shannon because she didn't know where
the two guys was it in next state the
two guys and I was there in the 500 and
the fact that nothing would happen to
them of it I mean it's it's it was
something you know this everything what
I saw it you know it was a young boy the
same thing you know he was a kept maker
I know them very what I I see him every
day I mean I see him in my mind my dream
I can see them
because we all work together so
fortunate that we were working when the
Pope was with a holley madonna
the black madonna is and we got in touch
going back and forth you know painting
you just people go back and forth is one
of the sisters and he told them the
story we wanna just save our kid how to
do it and he gave them an address in the
name of our former mate well whatever
they arranged that the mate will be as a
certain time at that place and the kid
will just walk out and so happen she
took the child and walked with the child
after the post office over there was
another woman they didn't know each
other who took over the child and that
woman brought the child into that
monastery to a closed door and she has
to leave there can't be no witnesses
then the door opened they took in the
child the child came and they have
listed as an infant an orphaned of
Polish officer no other child when I the
left second place had took away so I so
I be killed
because they're always real jumping next
day next day finish you know so I saw
and I had the connection in the from the
underground was a engineer electric in
ha thought he was living outside he
wasn't on the ground and he has the job
well as electric engineer in Hoffa in
the concentration camp where they were
metal factory was you know so I saw
maybe and then in the day they were kept
history in Devon do not let me out so I
have to I have to give the child that
person what I can have a connection with
him so I asked him I give it a so much
so much money to keep my child with you
child you know and he agree and I trust
him because he wasn't on the ground
we were extremely hungry all the time we
were getting a piece of bread maybe that
big dry bread for the whole day so some
of us could resist and take a little bit
in the morning a little bit noontime a
little bit an evening but most of us
aided right away in the morning and for
lunch we got some potato peel soup water
and potato peels for the evening there
was some results cafe some coffee
and that was what what we lived on three
years as far as I'm concerned I didn't
even hope for being saved we just knew
that some day we will die just like
everybody else
we looked out to the windows we saw
manga fights the Russian woman the temp
they had a whole battalion and he came
and he fought those Germans and he
wouldn't I saw so much debt again and
all of a sudden a young Jewish man ran
into the hall opened the doors and told
us come out come out we are free the
Russians are here the German is a
running away being in in Kim's being and
concentrate we were just fighting for
their everyday we never knew your all's
expect that any day is going to happen
something but after we were liberated
was set because we gonna go where you
going
no words home I went back and yes I want
to pick up my child I know she's in this
monastery but how are you gonna pick it
up she there as an orphan so my wife and
I went there and we start talking for
the nuns she didn't believe it she is no
parents
she's a devoted kid to Jesus Christ to
the church well he just couldn't let it
go by death he called in a one month in
another month and then came the head man
and we tried to converse them that this
is our child but then they came up with
a verdict let the child made her own
choice
she was walking from one end to the
other technically she did not what to do
finally she properly recognized me got
to me crying I wanna go with you
so one day I did from the antigravity
the people still there folks people you
know that nothing so they saw me in the
street come with us we're gonna drink
now so I you know a party from the other
guy I said I can go I have to look for
my child and I can trust them all for
the underground I don't know where's my
child so he he told me listen one you
have to know go down and there you hear
everything what happened and there is a
lake and I went there and I asked the
neighbors around like nothing the
outside woman told me when the Germans
were here somebody brought the child was
crying there was waiting we went out
from the lake in the man in the morning
we founded that child they would then we
saw them we told the Germans he said
that child in the water and I didn't
want to tell this my wife what will help
I had this in me
this is me and this is my friend who had
that picture she survived with her
father from the same city we were just
neighbors and very close friends and
this Helen and I are on the survivors
all these children these girls were
killed during the first action you know
just as they took people out five and
five there when they went to death and
we went to live life we were a family
for 96 people uncles aunts cousins
grandparents and I'm the only one I'm
still around people wonder why he never
smiled he never loved this part of our
brain is dead we don't know what it was
my child my daughter never laughs he's
now our own wonderful person she lives
in Los Angeles California and I have a
son who lives in Atlanta Georgia
he's married he went to law school so
was my daughter but the difference
between that child's life and my son is
in two worlds I was just like coming
back from granny's dad without feeling
here people live normally playing the
piano some inmates were trying to laugh
and he had near death
[Music]